This toy refuses to believe he's a toy, and
thinks he can fly. But rather than crush his
expectations, let's try using some chemicals
and craft supplies, to help get this little
space ranger, a little closer to living his
dream.
To start this project I went to the hobby
store for some glittering foam sheets and
a bottle of tacky glue. I also picked up a
couple of F-class rocket motors. And you can
see the code on the side indicates this
project really should not be duplicated. Now
we need a way to make our glitter sheets a
bit more rigid, so why not start by gluing
a scrap piece of cardboard to the backside
of the foam. Now this will start to curl up
as it dries, so we should probably use something
like a heavy book, to keep it as flat as possible.
Ok, now that the red sheet is drying, let's
cut a rectangle out of the blue foam, and
apply a liberal coat of glue to that one as
well. This piece is gonna wrap around the
sides of the motor tube, so if we press it
flat and carefully roll it up, this should
form a cool blue rocket body. Now let's check
on the red piece to see how it's doing. I
decided to trim the excess material around
the edges just to make it a little more convenient
to work with, and now we can add glue and
fold one of the edges back on itself to get
a double sided glitter effect. This piece
is gonna be used to make the fins, and
I'm gonna use the corner of a piece of
cardboard as a template. Now I'm sure you
can already figure out how this is going to
work. I traced 3 pieces the same size, then
cut along the lines, to get these sparkly
red fins that should all be about equal. Alright,
let's try adding a bit of hot glue to the
ends, and pressing them onto the rocket body.
Now, this typically isn't the best choice
to secure fins to a rocket, but the foam is
porous enough to make a surprisingly strong
bond. The next step is to make a nose cone,
and we can do that by cutting to the center
of a circle, then gluing it around the top
in a cone shape. This will help reduce the
drag a bit, but it's mainly just for looks.
Now as a fun finishing touch, I picked up
a package of alphabet stickers, and pressed
them directly onto the body tube. At this
point, our little rocket-ship is ready for
action. All we need now is a pilot. My 3 yr
old son said I could use his Buzz Lightyear,
so we used a bit of black electrical tape
to strap him on securely. Now this little
guy is sporting a powerful little rocket pack,
that's awesome, but the problem is that it's
extremely unstable. Now we might be able to
balance it out a bit with a long wooden dowel.
Let's secure the rocket at the top of the
dowel with some packing tape, then strap our
rocketeer back into place. As we look for
the center of gravity, you can see that just
by adding the stick, we've shifted the CG
behind the rocket. Hopefully, that'll be
enough to get this to work, but in either
case, our test pilot looks excited and ready
to go, so let's push a fuse up into the nozzle,
and try lighting it, with sunlight. Unlike
the movie, however, this guys helmet can't
actually focus the sunlight by itself. But
I do have a 2" acrylic ball that certainly
can. All we need to do now is sit back, and
enjoy the show.
Now it looks everything just
exploded, but surprisingly our hero made it
back with hardly a scratch. It looks like
he wants more, so let's go bigger. I made
the bigger one by cutting a toilet paper tube
lengthwise, secured it to the motor with some
glue, then reinforced the tube with a few
wraps of packing tape. This made a compartment
just big enough, for a makeshift parachute.
I made this one from a garbage bag and some
dental floss. You can see here, I reinforced
the eyelet holes with packing tape to prevent
the plastic from ripping. Next, I glued some
of the blue foam around the rocket body, pushed
the parachute into position, then pressed
the nose cone to fit snugly at the top. It
looks ready, so let's give it one final pre-flight
check, then light it up and back away.
Yeah, the parachute came out alright, but apparently,
we should have added a shock cord, because
dental floss isn't very flame resistant. Not
to worry though because it looks like our
action hero still wants more. I went to the
dollar store and got a pool noodle and some
flutter boards, then glued them together to
make "the biggest one". I tried building a
makeshift launch pad out of some wooden dowels,
and glued little PVC risers on the sides to
help guide it during the launch. Now let's
get ready for blastoff, making sure our captain
is nice and comfortable, give him a big salute,
and wish him the best, on his journey to infinity,
and beyond. If you were to ask him I'm sure
he'd agree, that flying a pool noodle rocket
was an epic way to end the day. Well now you
know how to use a few craft supplies to give
your favorite toys the ride of their life.
But, of course, you probably shouldn't.
If you do wanna play with rockets though, try
searching for nearby rocketry clubs and see
what they're up to. Well that's it for now.
If you liked this project, perhaps you'll
like some
of my others. Check them out
at www.thekingofrandom.com